you probably know that one of the key
ingredients to brewing beer is the yeast
and if you're a brewer you can buy many
different kinds of yeast commercially or
if you're like this brewery you can get
your yeast from the guts of wasps but
the guts of wasps well it turns out that
that's actually not such a crazy idea
I'm an instructor for the craft beer and
brewing essentials set aside view I'm a
beer enthusiast I'm a fan of Reznik I'm
combat composer I'm a head brewer and
co-owner of brass Nick fairy vinegar for
about 20 years now but brass nick is a
relatively new project or
just about to turn three years old what
is yeast yeast is a single-celled
microorganism
it belongs to the group of fungi as a
fungus it means that the organism relies
on external sources of food and so they
are very unique in the way they process
their food so they consume the sugars
and as a by-product they excrete alcohol
humans have been using yeast for
thousands of years we use it for making
bread for making beer wine and with the
advent of science we use it for other
things that bio technological industry
the pharmaceutical industry we depend on
East for producing insulin and so given
the relevant importance of breweries
there is seem to be a lack of
understanding of the ecology of the
organism itself brewers yeast was the
first complex organism to have its
genome sequence so a huge amount is
known about its genetics but we don't
really know where it came from this
prompted researchers to look for yeast
in different places in the wild and some
researchers from Italy fan brewers yeast
in the guts of wasps and so these guys
in Italy we're looking for mechanism
through which least survives outside of
man-made environments and they made some
experiments and found evidence to
suggest that Barozzi survives in the
gutter wasps through the up fruit season
so I just wanted to test whether we
would observe the same thing happening
in this part of the world or it was just
a localized phenomenon in continental
Europe we started opening the gut of
these wasps that we have here in British
Columbia and plating the contents to see
we
we're going to find Rosie's we found
this particular species of yeast that is
related to bruises but it doesn't fall
within the same natural group and the
species is called leshan sia thermal
tolerance so the yeast is using social
insects and hiding out in their guts
during winter and then in the spring
when the wasp makes its new nest it
passes that yeast on to its offspring
and then this gets passed out into the
wild it may be that there's other
insects that provide with that specific
habitat but there's something unique
that wasps provide by being social
organisms they depend on each other for
feeding and so that's how they made its
made from one generation to the next the
previous generations of yeasts that will
be later transported for the next cohort
of fruits they kind of hijack the
biology when scientists have looked the
East's in the wild they see a huge
diversity of different types but there's
a puzzle as to where these different
types come from when yeast is eating a
piece of fruit it reproduces by cell
division just cloning itself these can
also reproduce by exchanging genetic
information through sexual reproduction
triggering behaviors there's changes in
acidity and there's changes in nutrient
availability and so yeast responds to
that by one thing to reproduce
essentially and so that's what multiple
strains me coming to content and produce
hybrids something that yeast species
don't like to do when they're outside
reproducing sexually is a gamble because
the offspring might not be so good at
surviving in the same environment there
needs to be a good reason to take this
risk and this might be because of the
changing environment in the loss of guts
this is an important result as it gives
us one explanation as to where the
diversity of different yeast came from
so how do you go from finding
they cease in the guts of course when
deciding to make a Fiero okay I'm not a
brewer okay and so the answer to that is
you pass it on to the expert so you know
when we're making beer we cook what we
call the word that's basically a sugary
solution made from barley it's got hops
in it as well if you think of it a bit
like beer juice once we're done cooking
in the word we cool it down and that's
where we add yeast and these is what
turns that sugary solution into what we
know of as as beer you think stood like
a a week two depending on the east you
know it's not just a matter of producing
carbon dioxide and alcohol what's really
interesting about yeast is how it just
completely transforms the flavor of
what we start with amazing Everage one
of the things we do here is we use a lot
of a lot of yeast strains relative to
some other breweries you know it's
complicated to deal with a lot of
different key strains in one hurry but
it's something we have a lot of fun with
so so when the spat team came by asking
if they wanted to mess around with some
some keys to isolate lost guts they're
like yeah I thought most of the flavor
of beer came from the hops but it turns
out that yeast also plays a large role I
mean the hops are very important but he
says has a huge influence on flavor of
beer and all all yeast strains produce
at some degree esters and phenols and
those are compounds organic compounds
that that produce there are fruity or
spicy in some beers it's really the
yeast that is almost the most important
ingredient because
you know we say we do it stays on where
are you looking for like a bit of a
couples like a pair of character that's
it's the East it really does that what's
interesting is that yeast produces a lot
of chemical compounds as a result of its
metabolic pathways that it doesn't need
to produce just as five so hypothesis is
that yeast does this to attract the
wasps in order to then be eaten by them
but it's these compounds that we as
humans also enjoy I mean in some ways
were attracted to the same flavors
insects are so we just pretty much like
big walls where they yeah they've just
got graduated so thanks to Conrad and
Sebastian for showing me around for a
snake brewery and also telling me about
all the kind of crazy stuff they're
doing with the wasp Guppies it's been
really interesting if you're in the
Vancouver area how you recommend you go
check out brass night brewery it's
always got a very interesting selection
of beers on the highly recommended